all right Chuck yes Chuck uh where are
you from originally where did you grow
up originally I'm from Lebanon
Lebanon tell me about your
family I have four sisters and a brother
and me we are six of us and we grew up
very poor you know when I'm
weing
on so I had
[Music]
to skip the school to go to work because
in that country you can start work when
you're 9 or 10 years old so I was like
10 years old I start working to help my
mother to pay the rent and everything
else
so
1975 we decided to come to United States
we didn't have no Visa we didn't have no
money nothing think but we managed to go
to Cyprus with the small board from it's
and we went to suprus and I went to the
church there was the Armenian Church I
went there and ask them if they can help
me uh give me some place to sleep and he
goes yeah cross street in the park all
those Refugee people they have tent I
can give you a tent you can live in the
tent I said okay that' be cool so we
lived in the tent for almost 3
weeks uh when we were living in in the
tent managed to go and find a job again
in
Cyprus and I worked for two days two
weeks and from there we went to
Greece when we went to Greece and uh
want to take Visa to United States we
were there for like six seven months
trying to get Visa every day going to
Embassy every day every day they denying
us they denying us so after seven month
when we went to the Embassy again there
was a guy that we know him from uh
Lebanon and uh he says what are you guys
doing here I said man we're going to go
to uh United States but I can't get a
Visa by then my brother was in Chicago
already so uh he says give me the
passport let me see what I can do so we
gave the passport me and my mom it
didn't even take 5 minutes he came back
he goes here there's your Vis go pay
your
uh it's unbelievable so I called my
brother I said hey we got the Visa we
want to come he goes okay I'll send you
the ticket right now and he sent us the
ticket we went the St to
Chicago and uh I lived in Chicago almost
5 years so we decided to go uh to
California we heard that the border is
good and everything so we came to
California the only reason we came to
California is I had the second job when
I was working first job it was a
bartending you know I was making good
good money in 1977 1978 $100 a night it
was a big big big money you know so I
work for a couple of years I said hey
I'm going to save the money and go to
California I did save the money
everything I came to California with
$4,000 in my pocket I went on uh got a
uh gas station and when I was I had the
gas station the previous owner he was
pumping like 25 30
30,000 gallon every month when I took
over I start pumping 100 10,000 the
company see that and they came and talk
to me they go hey you're doing a good
job do you want the second uh second
location I said yeah but how much he
goes it's not going to cost you anything
company is giving it to you because
you're doing a good job so I got the
second gas station one in morovia one in
was
Covina and I was making between $25 to
$30,000 a month month I mean that was
big money in 1978
so uh then
uh I started for in drugs but then I
didn't any drugs 26 years old I didn't
know what drugs was so my my uh
brother-in my wife's
brother gave me little B it and he
says when you
dring uh sore this thing with put the
bot in your nose and sore it so we were
going to wedding me and my wife so we
got to wedding I I even forgot that I
had that b my jacket pocket top pocket
and uh I went to the bathroom I see
somebody was soring that's how I
remembered I got something in here so I
went to the bathroom and snowed it and
go back uh to the able start thinkinking
man I felt I feel like King I
mean drinking and C
cooking it was good so I after that I
start I got addicted to the C again I
started
smoking when I got real bad on it I used
to rent a hotel room I had $1600 habit
every single day every single day day so
for 2 years I did that but by then I
lost one of the gas station and 3 months
later I lost the other gas station and
uh my house mortgage I couldn't pay
because I was stealing myself so I sold
the
house I got divorced from my wife with
two
kids and
uh got divor from my wife and then I
came to smoke crack you know once I when
I once I got the crack I mean it was on
so I was smoking CRA I was passing my D
on Ma Park and here and uh yeah to keep
my addiction alive I started stealing
you know
me I'm ashamed of myself you know so I
started and I start doing P you
know shoplifting to support my habit you
know I went to they got CAU me one time
they gave me here in jail I didn't come
out and start doing again same thing it
didn't even take two months and did
again they C me they sent me to prison
this time for 3 years I got out of
prison 6 months I didn't do it bam again
I got hooked on it again I start doing
robberies and uh and B I went back to
prison again they gave me 4 years with
have at the time and fourth
time fourth time now I got three priers
fourth
time I was stealing again I got cut I
went to jail to the court and
everything I went to court and judge
says uh you got to do 25 to life for
just a p that because I had three
priors and my lawyer said that judge can
I talk to my
client and he came over my he says chck
I'm going to put five motion for you if
judge accept one of them at least one of
them you want to 25 to I said okay let's
go I didn't go to jury trial I just went
to judge
trial and my Lord up P My Lord a lot of
money and my Lord start looking to the
judge and uh he gave the paper to him
the motion and uh judge read and
everything he denied every one of them
every one of them he denied then he says
25 to life so I got 25 to life this is
1995 I went to
prison I was thinking I was 40 years old
I said by the time I get out of the
prison I'm only 65 66 you
know
uh so I went to prison and when I got to
prison just to relax and everything I
start doing
heroin start doing
heroin uh I used to melt to heroin like
not my uh
no for 2 years I did that for 2 years
then I said to myself Chuck what are you
doing you might get up you might they
might change the law and you you get up
because your case is not
violent okay I got out I got so sick
from the heroin for two three weeks oh
my God I couldn't I couldn't eat I
couldn't shower I was smelling in the S
my S was telling me get get up I'm going
take shower I said okay but I go back
they gave me some Morphin and everything
it didn't help at all at all so I did
cold turkey you know I did myself for a
week week and a half and I got I got
good you know so I was in Ironwood State
Prison my points dropped to level two
they sent me from ironwood to salad that
from salad that I was doing really good
that's why they send me sank went and I
did uh I stayed in s Quon and I went to
the school over there got my GED from
school I was doing really good really
good 2013 all of a sudden this prop 94
passed whoever don't have a violent
crime they can go home oh my God I was
so
happy so in two months when that prop 36
pass in two months my the counselor
called me to the office I went there and
I said what's up she goes guess what
you're going home but I had done 19
years already you know from from uh uh
uh 1995 to 2014 I had done 19 years
already anyway I was so happy I was
shaking I couldn't believe it you know
I'm going home you know uh yeah they
called me they said pack up you're going
I so pack up all my my stuff went to the
center they
they they took my picture and think they
give me $200 get money and I went out I
went out I went out and
uh my family my family was waiting on me
you know do you have children yes two
children and I had some grand kids there
by then so my family was waiting for me
they had a they had a table from here to
the wall about 30 40 people coming to
you know to tell me
hi so I went there it was good we drank
and ate and everything I mean I was
shaking
still after that I went home I said uh
no more no more you know so my my nephew
gave me a job he had a tire shop he gave
me a job he says you just deliver tires
you know he was paying me $500
a week I said
good fresh getting out the uh prison and
you getting that money a week it was
good so for 6 months I worked real good
with him 6 months February come and I
said
man I didn't do my 50th birthday let's
do my 60th birthday so I stopped doing
my 68 birthday I invited 250 people 250
people I invited to this Armenian
nightclub and uh it was good we drank we
dance we talk we left after that when I
went
home I'm sleeping I have my beuty amaz
and everything and that devil that a
monkey in my back St talking to me you
know hey Chuck you got all this present
today you have doing real good then
you're drinking you wife your wife you
guys were dancing but one thing is
missing right
now he says you got to go smoke
Rock I thought about it I said No 10 10
15 minutes later I said it I do it
one night my birthday and come home so I
got up and got rest and everything
I came up I no I came to M Park I got
some up and started
smoking that one night that I was going
to do it took me 6 months six months I
was out here getting
loaded you know and they didn't even
know where I am but they reported that
my car uh my car is stolen so that way
you know police can stop me and take the
car from
me
so yeah that one night I said I'm going
to go and go back home it took me 6
months so when I was there I was in
Huntington Beach driving to go you know
see what kind of shop I go in to steal
something because money is gone
already so in h Police Stopped me with
no reason no reason I was driving light
I was stopping them stops everything so
stop me I have punched up in the car I
have like two three pipes and uh police
stop me he goes I go sir why did you
stop me I didn't do nothing wrong he
goes yeah I know you didn't do nothing
wrong but your family called that you're
missing person you know I said okay I go
home right today he goes no no we got to
take your car they took my car they left
me without car because my sister knows
if I I don't have a car I can't go
nowhere I don't go back home but next
year I went uh rent a carard you know I
had a credit card I I rent a car for a
week uh $45 a day with the insurance and
everything so I had a rent a car I kept
it for like two months I was paying the
car every week you know and I was doing
my think again with the r car
so and then I went into AA meeting one
time and I liked it I started going to a
meeting in two weeks I quit smoking in
two weeks because I want to be member of
a family so in two weeks I stopped
smoking now I'm going like two meetings
a day three meetings a day you know
because I loved it and uh they help me
you know I had 1 month I got a chip I
have 3 months I got a chip I had 6
months I got a chip then birthday came
up they gave me the cake and everything
so I got clean and I was clean for 7 and
1/2 years 7 and 1/2 years I was
clean and then 5 months
ago five months ago my good friend
died she was 26 years old
we used to love each
other she died over those same
night when I see that I said okay I got
to get me some drugs then come down
that's why I came here and I've been
here since my parent doesn't even know
where I'm
at am I dead am I know am I
alive they don't know nothing I haven't
called them I don't talk to any member
of my family I'm pretty sure that they
come into m m park side looking for
because they know that I go over there
they don't know this spot no I bet you
every day they go going and looking for
me but they can't find me
so one reason I came here I swear to God
I'll tell you the truth one reason I
came here I wanted to
die since my girlfriend died I wanted to
die too but I'm so that I
can't put that bad little needle in my
arm shoot it and pass out you
know so hopefully God will take my life
different
way and I go meet my good up
there that's why I'm
here I think there's a better
way
after 7 and 1 half years clean I came
back
again I don't think killing yourself is
the way
Chu your girlfriend wouldn't want you to
die nobody wants you to
die yeah I my
I mean I had lot lot of hisory about my
life
but
uh and I'm glad that I came here today I
the guy outside called me he goes Chuck
come in you're doing interview you get
$100 I said man that's good so that's
why I came here because my car is on
Gladius and P it's been parked there for
a week because I need the standing upper
standing column it's $150 and I don't
have that money so this $100 is going to
help me see if I can get $50 from
somewhere else I can change that I'm a
mechanic too I can change that St stay
in calm and I have my car we can have I
I don't have a car I'm just walking what
what do you think the answer is for you
if if if you weren't going to try to
kill
yourself to get your life straight the
answer my be
is come to myself and go back go back
home to my family yeah I mean that
that's just but I don't know how they
going to
react I want to go
home miss
my
so I don't know what to do
so right now it's been a week that I'm
thinking to go back home enough is
enough God want want me God don't want
me yet speaking to a therapist about
everything you're feeling and going
through is probably going to help
you I'm like C and myself you know had a
good job and
everything so you just showed me your
that you're an you're an addiction
counselor yeah how long how long did you
do
that five five and a half years so the
the counselor needs a
counselor I'm a shame I'm a sham oh my
God my
children wasn't talking to me because
I'm using drug so when I got 7 and 1
half years clean my younger daughter
start talking to me I'll be able to go
to her house and play with the kids and
everything you know my grandkids but my
older
daughter she was still not talking to
me but since I was in aa aa taught me a
lot of
patient patient patient it might take 10
years to come back to me and talk to me
but I have to have a patient and I I
didn't get mad I didn't go and get H
about it you know I just let it go she's
she's seeing she's hearding that how
that doing you
know
sir I got a to Cora here and at the
house I got 2022 Mercedes 82 8 to 20 I
mean I was doing real good real good now
in the this five months all my credit
card are full my bank account I'm $900
overdraft I'm in dip no now my car
is up I don't know how to fix it because
I don't have the money I need $150 to
fix my car I can have a car like
tomorrow morning I can go get the parts
and fix it but I don't have the
money so that's why when he called me I
came running over here to get 00 and
find some another $50 from somewhere if
I can and fix my car I can give you a
little
extra thank you so I appreciate God
bless you man God bless you I hope you
maybe this interview will change change
me too does it help to talk about this
yeah it might change my life listen to
you people like you care about people
and you bringing and hearing his his
story
that's that's awesome that's awesome God
bless you guys man for doing this God
bless you you
know that's it sir all right Chuck I
wish you the best of luck thank you sir
thank you love to hear from you in few
months or a year thank you
sir
that